welcome to the property investors
youtube channel which i believe to be
the richest more is the realest prophecy
resource on the pall of things so just
get subscribed right now right below and
join the family tim is an absolute
pleasure to have you here with us at the
hunt of all you'll notice the property
finance coach that's correct yeah thanks
Samuel thanks very much for inviting me
here it's a real pleasure thanks for
coming down who knows you're a few years
now yes the atmosphere why don't you
start by just explaining what the
property finance code means so the
property finance cage I identified that
one of the biggest blockers for people
in property investing we're experiencing
with the lack of Finance the lots of
courses on helping people how to adapt
various strategies but there was very
little advice on actually how to work
with investors so I thought that's an
area that I can help and really add
value to so that's that's kind of how
that came about that's great fantastic
and you're an investor user I'm an
investor myself yeah I have a very small
portfolio of just single out properties
but aside from that I also do joint
ventures with other people and yeah
there's been some interesting learnings
on the way but those learnings are great
for being able to help other people
and do you think that you can start off
with no money and through your ventures
and very environment you can build a
large pretty portfolio and become
financially independent starting with
nothing starting with nothing I did
slightly better than that when I started
I didn't just have no money I had about
- about a hundred thousand pounds
through a project that didn't quite work
out so you might say I was quite
motivated to make something work for me
so yes absolutely you can start with
nothing or less than nothing and even if
you've got money at some point you're
going to run out
so working with investors is is
absolutely key part to growing your
property portfolio because of course
it's you're born someone else do a deal
but you're going to get instant return
on investment absolutely and one of the
key things working with investors is
understanding the kind of deals that you
need to be doing that will work for
investors at a meeting just before I
came here and we're talking about the
kind of deals that would actually work
because one of the keys working
investors they want to know how they're
going to get their money back so it's
not like working with your own money
where it may be okay to leave some of
the money in it's preferable if you can
get all of your money out and you've got
a strategy for being able to do that so
I'm going to be asking lots of questions
okay in your brain and hopefully we'll
be delving in and learning a lot of
information about practically how to
funding bills and how to how to get the
finance you know before before we do
that
why don't you start just by telling us a
little bit about yourself in your
background and how you ended up getting
into property in the first place how I
ended up getting into property when I
was there and interesting I ran the New
York Marathon in 2011 aged 50 and I came
back from that thinking boy I've been
able to achieve that it's quite an
achievement it was absurd marathon that
I'd run and came back really inspired
and thought at the time I was a garden
designer a successful garden designer
loving doing that work and helping
people transform their gardens but I
realized that when I had my pension
valued and they said Tim you know
congratulations your pensions going to
be worth about five thousand pounds and
I said five thousand pounds a month is
fine
and they said no Tim it's it's not a
month it's a year and that's in 15 years
time so I thought great okay so I
couldn't carry on with the horticulture
because I've literally been digging my
own grave and that didn't really appeal
so I thought yeah let's let's start
exploring what the options are
and when I came back from New York I got
involved with all sorts of internet
marketing and get rich quick quick
schemes and and actually one of those
led me to what was at the time the
Wiltshire property meet and we were
there to present the internet marketing
idea but actually I fell in love with
the property and saw that there was far
more legs if you like to that as a
proposition for a long term to never
some of these these kind of harum-scarum
internet schemes but we're about at the
time so it was kind of yeah just
understanding that I need to do
something I needed to create a legacy
firm for my children I needed to create
that time freedom for me to be able to
go and enjoy my life
yeah that's great so so what do you my
marathon yeah or I'm unstoppable
has been pretty active you then check
tide attention realize itself yes as
most people do realize that have
pensions you have you wanted to leave a
legacy that you tried a few things
individually in property yeah great and
that was when you are 50 and hau'oli
actor behind fifty six six years ago six
years ago that was so and what would you
say in the last six years would be your
greatest achievement in prata
my greatest achievement has to be that
I've raised around about two and a half
million pounds in private investor
finance which is yeah I've been very
modest about it it was something I had
to do in a way but it's taught me a lot
of lessons about how to work with other
people and yeah it is it is quite an
achievement to to have done that
particularly when you look at at the
time I was I was leveraging other
people's experience and their knowledge
and their skill so you know when people
come to me and say well I haven't got
money I said what
you know I started with -100 I didn't at
that time have necessarily all the
experience but I was working with with
other people and leveraging that in
order to make to achieve that level of
success well people would tell you that
it was impossible really night is your
yeah you know if it is and you started
out with less than nothing you're a
hundred grand in debt you know they're
raising two and a half million to invest
in property and become a property
investor will be a quiet room to most
people yeah what would you say to
somebody who said it
you know stone attic box you've no money
and raising finance all that it's risky
dodgy it's carved and it's just a pipe
dream that's not going to work
yeah it is all of those things it is
risky it is dodgy you know it is hard
work
yeah I had an email just before I came
here somebody one of my clients you know
feeling a bit disheartened you know you
need to be persistent you need to
understand what you're doing you need to
get a real feeling for the numbers what
works for you why it's a good deal and
because if you don't you will
potentially fall foul of the many traps
and things that you can fall into with
property and you know I think we all
acknowledge that there are risks
attached with property it's you know any
investment of any description carries
risks it's understanding those risks and
how to mitigate them and particularly
when you're working with private
investors you've really got to
understand them and be able to
communicate them effectively with with
your investors so that they understand
what they're letting themselves in for
and how you're mitigating those risks by
you know taking steps and understanding
what the risks are and if somebody you
say there are no risks involved in
property you know run a mile run a mile
very quickly you know maybe 26.2 miles
when you run the marathon I think it's
about at the Adhan environmentally
intelligent
to limit those those risks and you
prevent anything from happening but of
course tonight because you've always got
some level of risk even when you drive a
car you know you might crash so yeah
pretty much the thing about that is
nobody expects you to know everything
about every aspect of any property deal
so it's cool to be working with other
people you've got that knowledge and
that expertise and we you know highly
recommend that people have you know
expert legal advice that they have the
tax accounting particularly specific for
property so they're getting the best
advice and the best people and also to
to kind of work with people who've got
the experience and got the knowledge
maybe made a few mistakes one of my
coaches shared with me that I'd learn
nothing from his successes but
everything from his failures because
when things go right you don't know
where the boundaries are you don't know
what the limits are whether whether the
limit side kids are great at this
because they push the boundaries the
whole time they push the envelope
see what's possible and yeah they pull
over and they hurt themselves and of
course as adults we pick them up and
dust them down and you know you wouldn't
know about Parenthood just yet but I
gather that's coming your way very thin
okay perfect it's a good lower it's a
good low with that person it what would
you say to somebody come on guys like
this all the time they'll learn houses
you hate your nose or when get really
high we've been on investment and I do a
couple of deals for then suddenly of
course they're limited because they've
run out finance yeah so they're ditching
owners and I do there are options lease
option agreements and there are no exam
yet where you can do it
yep shop or grazing finance if you've
been Tina has played for grounds I have
turn that into a generating ten grand a
year yeah we have a program sure it
makes sense to borrow off somebody give
them back a small percentage
keep the rest and at the property as
well yes I've done that myself not on
the same level to what you've done it
but I for a couple hundred thousand
pounds yeah what would you what advice
would you give to somebody
it was wanting to do that I didn't have
anyone that was there to give them a
name instead what the right table was to
do how they know that Allah gave attic
well we we work on what I call the four
PS of raising Private Finance so there
are the four key elements to raising
finance so there's the people aspects of
it and property is very much about
people we also need to understand the
project we under need to understand the
paperwork side of things and we need to
understand the PR and the way I kind of
share this with people is that we people
in the UK have a real problem that
asking for money and it's this real kind
of blocker vert you know I'm going to be
asking for money
and it's not about that at all it's not
the all of a syndrome where you know
please sir can I have some more this is
about creating an opportunity presenting
an opportunity and making it attractive
and the story that I tell is about
attracting butterflies into a garden
having come from a horticultural
background you know there's several ways
you can you can catch a butterfly you
can stand in a garden with a butterfly
net
you wait for a butterfly to run to fly
over and you can run around the garden
chase after it and hope you catch it
that's a way it's a bit random you know
you might not end up with a kind of
butterfly do you want if you want
cabbage white planting cabbage white
cabbages in your garden will attract
them in droves because it's what they
want to be able to lay their eggs for
their capture
you know the caterpillars to be able to
to feed to grow to become butterflies
cabbage whites aren't terribly exciting
so maybe you want something a bit more
exotic a bit more exciting perhaps like
a red admiral or a painted lady and you
plant pops of bubblier which will
attract them in in droves so you've got
to run around chasing after them you're
creating the environment that's
attractive
you the kind of people that you want to
be working with as investors that's a
great analogy on a practical level yeah
what would that look like wanting to
attract somebody who's very paper and
all over the line yeah so sharing your
story and resonating with those people
so understanding what their problems are
you know particularly at the moment
interest rates are pretty much still at
an all-time low so if they've got money
sitting in a bank it's earning them
probably less than 1% you know when
you've got inflation taken into connects
actually costing the money to have that
money sitting in a bank account or a
building society so understanding the
pain that they're feeling by having that
money sitting there not working for them
and unconventional that they can safely
invest in property working with somebody
who who knows what they're doing always
working with somebody that knows what
they're doing and you know allows them
then to explore those possibilities and
there's plenty of money out there I
think this is the big myth you know I
get asked all the time you know well
who's got money
I'm sorry they don't walk down the
street with a whopping great flag saying
hey I've got a hundred grand stashed in
the bank you know come and month me you
know it's it's just not happening so you
know quite often the guys who've got the
outward symbols of success whatever that
means you know the big house the flash
car the expensive holidays you know
they're not necessarily the guys that
have got money you want to invest in
because they've spent it all on their
toys that's perhaps a bit of a broad
generalization so how much other than
what you've you show you success on
Facebook
yeah I use Facebook I probably had the
greatest success on LinkedIn linked
LinkedIn post just shared that I was
doing a particular project shared be
outlined details of that project
to be a bit careful these days because
the FCA obviously the rules and
regulations about how you can promote
investment opportunities so again you've
got to be a bit careful with that but
there are ways there's some really good
fashion things you post on LinkedIn and
I've got this deal yeah and you do it
not in this very way but just go just
for the record I worked on this project
now is generating some I think um yeah
how ontario and then you're going to
have yeah i'm interest is mapped on
things yeah what was the next episode
one of the ways of doing it and to
getting greater you know some people
come to me and say well I've only got
maybe 100 contacts you know relatively
few contacts in this day of you know
being able to connect so easily you know
they've been they're not out there and
they haven't perhaps got lots of
contacts at the moment but it's not just
appealing to those hundred it's their
contacts as well so you're leveraging
not just the finance but you're
leveraging people and it's presenting an
opportunity in such a way that's asking
the question who else might be involved
in this who you know who might also be
interested in this as an opportunity
because quite a lot of the cash that
I've bought in has come from people that
I've never met before that I wasn't
connected to yeah you know two hundred
thousand pounds at a time in some
instances from people and maybe you know
you know they were signing it off before
they'd actually even met me because I
created that that correct environment
the environment that were resonated with
them it provided a solution for they
were looking for at the time and and it
met with their requirements so it was
sort of a no-brainer for so you got the
four keys so you've got the project yeah
I presume that's not something that you
to be huge or special and it's not
something I specialize in but what I
what I do encourage people to do is to
really understand the numbers and the
key particularly when you're working
with investors is the exit strategy are
not just to have one exit strategy it
might be your
one strategies that keep the property so
you can build your portfolio but
actually in reality it may be that you
can't refinance it to quite the level
that you wanted to because you don't
have control over the revaluation for
the mortgage so you might end up having
to sell it in order to exit but you need
to understand the dowser where's your
phone yeah you definitely lots of yeah
yeah one of the exits may be the you
know for that particular investor Verte
actually you bring another investor on
board and you know as long as your your
transputer one of the big words for all
investors talked about is transparency
that's what they're looking for they're
looking for you know no little hidden
surprises that they're suddenly going to
find kind of creeping out of the
woodwork they accept others risk they
want to know what the risks are they
want to understand you're managing them
and that that's that's really critical
to getting getting the whole thing
sorted out so once you've got the
project and you've got people
approaching you so interested we do and
it appears the paperwork is the
paperwork she was just a summary on how
do that like Mike reference particularly
at the moment is to work with loan
agreements rather than doing joint
ventures now don't get me wrong there is
a time and place for joint ventures but
they're much more complicated and a
blank sheet of paper is effectively a
joint venture agreement you can write on
it whatever you want and that's a joint
venture agreement and you need if you're
working with other people's money for
joint ventures they've got to through
again the FCA rules and regulations
they've got to be either high net worth
individuals or sophisticated investors
so you've got to get you know people
signed off to say that they are who they
say they are and they've got that level
of experience to go into what I've also
heard is that I think it's something
like 80% of all joint ventures don't
work they fail to meet the expectations
of both parties for the
involved with a project and that's
because people don't tend to get the
sweets of the nitty-gritty before they
start kind of going on and doing the
project they jump into bed together
without really understanding or what
happens when things don't go quite
according to plan there's no exit
strategy there's no plan there's no kind
of grievance procedure for how you
handle that a loan agreement by contrast
a very simple document because you're
borrowing an agreed amount of money for
example one hundred thousand pounds you
borrowing it for Aniplex length of time
typically maybe twelve months perhaps
two years you know depending on what's
agreeable with the investor and you've
got probably a fixed rate of return so
there's no argument about any of it it's
plain and simple it's in black and white
there's nothing to argue about
the bigger the JV agreement that you've
got the more opportunity there is for a
lawyer to say I'm sorry we don't agree
with that or we've interpreted this in a
slightly different way
what's Oliver's only those little
opportunity give your client depends a
little bit on what the project is and
what it whilst and what you can afford
to give and that that's that's pretty
good in terms of you know typically
between six and eight percent you've got
to look at what people would be
expecting outside of property so if if
they were looking at other investments
what kind of would be on a par with with
the levels of risk attached to it so
yeah a six to eight percent would be my
my kind of target benchmark and what do
you go to your PR okay so we talked
about transparency with investors and
it's just PR is Investor Relations but I
couldn't think of anything else
beginning with P to make sure be a half
we came up with investor relational PR
and it's just keeping them informed and
you know acknowledging that there are
problems just keeping them informed
sharing with them the progress how you
getting on
what's going on with the project you
know what issues you've found how you're
solving the problems that have come up
and just keeps them engaged so you know
if you've got an investor that's working
with you for a year or maybe two years
they don't want you just disappear off
the planet the minute you've got their
cash things that they want to be kept
informed they want to be kept abreast of
what's happening with the particular
projects and stuff so it's really just
keeping them sweet and acknowledging
that you know there are challenges that
do arise in property and and how you're
managing them what do you do you've got
a hard fast tight agreeing with somebody
on a personal loan yeah and the deal
goes problematic and you lose the
investors money what happens then yeah
that's you know where you've got things
like personal guarantees you have you
know maybe some sort of security be
given exit strategies you know yes it's
possible to lose people's money I think
people need to be aware of that but if
you don't need you did due diligence
properly and you you you're not doing
anything that's super risky you know it
of course it's Never Say Never but if
you do it properly and you really done
your due diligence properly the
incidence what that's happening yeah
yeah yeah I mean it's at that yeah it's
understanding what the risks are I'm
being prepared to work with them and
again if you've got a good relationship
with the investor and they understand
the risks and understand what your exit
strategies are you know and they've
asked the right questions then you know
you should be it should be cool with it
and your freedom today I give in to
speaking at the property investor
circles oh yeah yeah it's like about
that what are you talking about are we
talking about how people can
start with nothing and raise private
finance from armchair investors or
property and you've got a book coming
out as well
I've got a book coming out later this
year which is called
how to attract armchair investors for
property and it's there yeah by by
contacting me and so that Tim up
property finance coach and yeah be happy
to put you on the list and alert you to
to the launch date when when that
actually goes live so we got the the
formatted manuscripts has literally
arrived in my inbox this morning so I've
got the job of proofreading that and
just making sure we've got the the
Kindle account all set up the Amazon
accounts all set up so we're just
waiting really to do some promotional
work to ensure that we've got number one
bestseller status for that book raise my
profile and obviously the key behind
this though is it's not so much about me
people talk about the reason why I just
love helping other people to succeed and
if I can help even one person break
through that limiting belief and help
them to get on the thing you know though
I'm a happy man and I'm hoping well I'm
sure that but we'll be able to change
people's perception of the fact that it
is possible the people are doing it
there's plenty of money out there and
it's it's just about the right approach
and breaking down those limiting beliefs
that's great well I'm really happy on
our news they haven't booked any evening
with you anybody's final words we've
done before we'd rather final words of
wisdom yeah I think perseverance is the
is is probably the 15 yeah there we go
we've created a 50 you know this stuff
isn't necessarily straightforward and
easy and I think if it was everybody'd
be doing it and actually that would make
it even harder
fact is that there are relatively few
people doing it there are lots of
properties out there there's lots of
people with money he'd love a great
return on their investment if you
present the right opportunity to them in
the right way and that they resonate
with you as an individual people by
people it's not so much about the
project it's it's do they connect with
you and some of the people will connect
with you because of who you are people
will connect with me for a completely
different reason because of who I am and
understanding that we are individual
that we resonate on different
frequencies is brilliant because it
means that there isn't a limited pool
that we're all fishing from together and
that is abundant and by persevering we
can actually break through into that and
make real progress and activities and
fantastic thanks don't you chase